security experts are urging business
owners and local officials to do more to
prepare for active shooter situations
and roughly the last two weeks there
have been four shootings its so-called
soft targets around the country those
places traditionally have little or no
security in place where via franca is in
Fort Worth Texas with a look at how a
local landmark there is preparing for
potential violence Omar good morning
good morning Billy Bob's is a massive
honky-tonk here in Fort Worth right next
to three major universities and last
night was College night a night that can
bring in about a thousand students and
folks here who are in charge of security
are serious about ensuring their safety
it's Thursday night at Billy Bob's a
Fort Worth landmark that bills itself as
the world's largest honky-tonk we do
bull-riding every Friday and Saturday
night Chris Knowles is Billy Bob's
manager he says about 6,000 people show
up on weekends for a big concert which
makes security a chief concern before a
person enters the building they're
already looked at two to three times if
surveillance cameras is what we do we do
and then they pass two checkpoints where
their ID by individuals as well and
despite a presence of 75 security guards
that includes Fort Worth police officers
Billy Bob's goes one step further with
its own employees do you guys have
active shooter training we do all our
management staff is trained on active
shooter procedures it seems like an odd
question but is that the time we live in
unfortunately yes and also unfortunately
you can never protect yourself a hundred
percent there are active shooter
incidents in bars around our country
every weekend
Robert Smith trained security personnel
at venues nationwide and says soft
targets like Billy Bob's need to have a
plan in place there's no change in the
training for a nightclub a bar a sports
venue a church a synagogue and if the
plan is to duck and hide duck and hide
and if your plan is to run to the
nearest exit get out
after the shooting at borderline Bar and
Grill in Thousand Oaks California
Wednesday night police said that kind of
thinking may have saved lives they ran
out of back doors they broke windows
they went through windows they hid up in
the attic they hid in the bathroom so
they unfortunately our young people are
people of nightclubs have learned that
this may happen for patrons at Billy
Bob's knowing the venue is prepared
makes all the difference
especially for Graham Wetherspoon who
brought his kids to play a couple rounds
of pool in Texas you can open carry and
conceal carry your handgun if you have a
permit but it's worth noting that a lot
of places in Texas that serve booze like
Billy Bob's do not allow you to bring
your gun inside viana that is a good
point and look I understand the need for
this but it just pains me that young
people in this country are gonna have to
get used to these kind of shootings and
train from an early age for school
shootings right now you can't even go to
a bar or restaurant without our
synagogue where yoga studio I mean we
really have reached the point where no
matter where you are it's it's not safe
but I do think we have to start thinking
about it and having a plan someone said
to me whatever you do run some people
freeze or they start calling 911 that's
the worst thing you can do you just got
to move you've got to move a lot of
guitar to hit a moving target I'm told
it's a new normal unfortunately